продовжуй працювати після обіду,
я все одно хотів би запросити вас зробити
щось дуже важливе, що ми
збираємося зробити зараз, безумовно, у
нас є хороший
вибір
учасників дискусії, я хотів би запросити
Петра Каржевського,
я думаю, що всі його знають,
так, він був у  ветеринар протягом 16 років
свого часу він був заступником голови
департаменту ветеринарної медицини, і ви ніколи не благословляли
тоді він був заступником міністра,
який першим реалізував
проект, який
ми зараз святкуємо, хто брав участь
у виборі пілотного регіону
і зараз  він очолює
там департамент, навіть цивільна та
військова адміністрація
дуже вітає та аплодисменти Петру,
приїжджайте сюди Петро,
другий учасник дискусії
заступник директора
департаменту освіти та науки з
них живуть,
тому адміністрація вона відповідала за
освіту  процес під час
безпосередньої загрози обстрілу,
і вона справді працювала 24 години на добу, не
покидаючи території,
перш ніж
вона стала свідком подій Миколая
та робила все, щоб освіта
розвивалася далі, — директор
департаменту наукової освіти
Левівської обласної
адміністрації
Обеліск відомий своєю
красивою  та інноваційні рішення та
одні з найкращих у країні, я думаю,
я в цьому впевнений, тому що я
також працюю там, а
не на шкоду іншим регіонам,
хлопці,
і з нами є Вікторія Балута,
молодший радник,
і все це стосується проекту  фактично ЄС
для навичок,
кращих навичок для сучасної України, вітаємо
Вікторію, я
сама математик, я пропоную
погратися з нашою арифметикою, у
вас є три хвилини, щоб відповісти на кожну,
щоб мати більше часу на питання після цього,
і ми шукатимемо онлайн-
коментарі в чаті  а також тих, хто
тут присутні,
ми хочемо зібрати якомога більше запитань і
коментарів,
щоб правила були викладені, вони
прості, і
я хотів би почати з бензину,
наш гуру
ветеринарів,
бензин,
будь ласка, дайте нам
три позитивні зміни, які
трапилося в системі професійної освіти у вашому регіоні,
можливо, пізніше в усій країні, ну
насправді перше, що нам
вдалося, але спочатку я хочу почати з
аналізу
системи професійно-технічної освіти та
системи попередньої підготовки,
я також хотів би  якщо
згадати комунікаційну стратегію, яку
ми насправді не описували,
не описали, що ми розробили,
і це стало міцною опорою для
подальшого розвитку Річі,
ми також змогли модернізувати це в
регіонах, які були взяті як пілотні,
і ми створили широку
лінію фронту  для цього
ми розширили кількість регіонів до 21, тож
потім довелося виключити їх, тож ми
залишилися з 19 із них, гарна
географія,
і тепер ми можемо
говорити про систему ветеринарної медицини в усій
країні, дякую, за короткий час і дуже
всеосяжний lud Міллер те саме запитання
до вас.
Я хотів би зосередитися на останніх роках,
а також на часі агресії.
Позитивним моментом є те, що ми
змогли довести собі
всім, що педагоги — це дуже
сильна команда
і справді  сильна когорта, яка
представляє серце галузі,
е-е,
близько 52 відсотків населення mikolai Robles
залишилося після початку
вторгнення, але все ж ми змогли
виконати майже 80 відсотків
освітнього замовлення,
тоді ми змогли підключитися до
дітей, що залишилися  в селі
снігуринка
підключити їх і дозволити їм
продовжувати навчання, і незважаючи ні на
що
у вересні ми мали більшість шкіл, які
працювали офлайн,
я вважаю, що це не маленьке досягнення,
так, дякую,
людям не потрібні три хвилини
вони здатні зробити це
за одну хвилину,
я пам'ятаю, що минулого року
11 шкіл були зруйновані в
області, що робить життя, не кажучи вже про
снігорифікацію, до
речі, постраждала від повені
через тупий тупий вибух
зараз Олег
деякі позитиви перші три
перші  три, які я придумав, ми
запровадили чітку систему
критеріїв Cuts для оцінки
кожного елемента, що круто, на основі того, що ми
можемо прийти до управлінських рішень,
по-друге,
на основі висновків зі стратегії,
ми змогли запустити просування
система для просування цієї системи в
школах, і вже третій рік поспіль у
нас зростає кількість
[музики]
абітурієнтів,
і фактично ми займаємо перше місце в
країні за цією кількістю,
і третє місце полягає в тому, що ми насолоджуємося
постійна увага до ветеринарів протягом більше
року. Головна
цифра
полягає в тому, що
системі ветеринарної медицини цього року буде виділено
понад півмільярда зелених насаджень
на розвиток.
Так, ми представляємо різні регіони з
моїми колегами. Людмила представляє
зобов’язання, яке все ще є  під сильними
обстрілами вони відчули на собі тягар війни. На
100 відсотків
живі, всі щасливі в регіоні,
ми
здебільшого мали справу з ВПО,
і я хотів би подякувати кожному
присутнім тут директору кожної ветеринарної школи
за те, як вони залучилися
з перших днів  війна
жодна інша галузь не змогла
відреагувати так швидко, про що
говорив Елект Паска, про
це добре Інвестиції
були зароблені керівниками шкіл
усіма речами, щоб
усі побачили, наскільки важливою
є ветеринарна сфера, про
це
часто не помічали раніше, але ця війна
справді сприяла  зараз це дуже помітно,
Вікторія,
ви можете бачити всю Україну, що ви
думаєте про зміни, що змінилося,
ви не залучені до цієї системи
одразу, але все ще працюєте над
нею,
тому шановні колеги Партнери, друзі,
доброго дня, дякую за запитання.
позитивних змін у сфері
професійно-технічної підготовки я
вперше згадав про підтримку цієї
цифровізації, у нас було багато заходів,
спрямованих на
розвиток цифрових компетенцій,
зокрема для вчителів у системі
та для студентів, а також
ми брали участь у оновленні веб-сайтів або
ветеринарних шкіл
близько 120  з них було оновлено
Мені близько
000 вчителі вдосконалили свої цифрові
навички, і я кажу грамотність
Розберг
створив у школах, щоб полегшити
перехід на формат онлайн-формату з
бажаного часу,
який став ще більш актуальним і
актуальним із пригодою  війна,
що дозволяє продовжувати навчання цих
студентів,
я б також згадав про підтримку
впровадження компетентнісного
підходу, у нас було розроблено багато курсів
для керівників шкіл для
вчителів,
ну магістрів освіти, навіть для студентів,
також у темі перебудови до
навчання  для різних професій і для
знань Mustang
також проект
був пов’язаний із закупівлею
певного
обладнання, наприклад 3D-принтерів, інтерактивних
панелей,
планшетів, ноутбуків, і це справді
мало позитивний вплив на ветеринарів в Україні.
та Навчання в
Україні
через соціальні медіа, які популярні серед
молоді, також через розвиток
мережі центрів розвитку кар’єри
ми також проводили тренінги для
співробітників таких центрів,
а також проводили психологічні консультації
в областях, ми отримали досить
позитивні відгуки, і ми маємо намір
продовжуйте, що в майбутньому,
на жаль, триває війна, і
в можливий період це буде
затребувано, дякую,
тому ми збираємося завантажити всіх, хто
дотримується часового проміжку Лотті,
і тепер це не питання безпосередньо до вас,
Перемога, а скоріше
запитання до цих адміністраторів, тож,
хлопці, ви представляєте пілотні регіони у
першому списку,
три із семи, які були
обрані Обіном також для патрулювання, тож
запитання до вас,
Вікторія згадала багато речей,
виконаних проектом, і дякую за
це,
тепер ви знали,  дизайн проекту
зовнішні
очікування проекту
просто для того, щоб сказати, чи могло щось
трапитися, але чи ні чи
ні, так,
знаєте, насправді було дуже приємно,
що ми не дотримувалися дизайну
проекту протягом усього чотирирічного
періоду
проекту  натомість була досить гнучкою,
і це дозволило максимально
залучити ветеринарні школи по всій
Україні, тож у нас були пілотні програми, які можна було
легко запровадити,
ми приєдналися до програми Erasmus Plus, про яку ми навіть не
мріяли, і ми маємо деякі позитивні
тенденції,
щоб зробити цю систему в Україні
привабливою для інвестицій
Говорячи про агентів змін, я думаю, що
проект сприяв тому, що ці
агенти змін спеціально навчені
люди з необхідними навичками краще знають,
як проводити кар’єрні консультації, як
покращити цей імідж,
як перейти від професійно-технічної
освіти до професійної
підготовки,
як побудувати  траєкторія навчання
та пов’язані речі,
що не сталося добре, робота, чіткий
намір, це все для партнерів,
країни-партнери, гендерні зусилля, щоб отримати
е-е-е,
повноцінне стажування,
і цього не сталося переважно не
тому, що вони цього не хотіли, а
тому, що
вони  якби ця пандемія прийшла до
війни, і це дійсно
змінило наші пріоритети,
з іншого боку, було б приємно побачити більше цифрового контексту контактів іншого вмісту,
але з огляду на пандемію, ймовірно, у нас його взагалі не було б,
але пандемія таки
сприяла і  це стало перевагою,
фактично
центри практичної підготовки, до яких
спочатку ставилися
скептично, е-е,
тепер думки змінилися, і ми
знаємо, що ці центри можуть
видавати дипломи,
тож я думаю, м’які навички для викладачів
у ветеринарних школах
тепер  New Normal буде використовуватися для
вимог важких навичок, ми хотіли трактори
, комбайни
та інше таке важке обладнання, як
це зробити, але це було в минулому, тепер настав час
подумати про м’які навички, оскільки це
стосується розвитку людського капіталу,
і в цьому відношенні проект  був
величезним успіхом, і я погоджуюся з Ріною, що
я б все ж сказав, що це не
крапка зараз, коли ми святкуємо, а
скоріше кома,
тому що більше проектів обов’язково
з’являться, будуть масштабні проекти,
і, ймовірно, буде задіяно більше людей і регіонів
гаразд, дякую, важливі речі, які
ви згадали, тому що вони кажуть, що
зміни можливі, коли всередині є
позитивні практики та агенти змін,
і це те, що ми знову
підкреслюємо,
і проект поставив
вам те саме запитання, Люк
Міллер,
це не так  легко говорити після моїх
колег, те, що
мій колега згадав, абсолютно
правильно,
я хотів би просто
поговорити більше про них регіон співпраці,
звичайно, це було обладнання для
сільського господарства, це
також була велика підтримка, але в
рамках проекту ЄС для навичок ми
мали можливість провести тиждень у
регіоні Левібе, поділитися своїм
досвідом і
отримати досвід,
гм, я вважаю, що досвід дуже
цінний, і він є подарунком
для нас, це кілька мільйонів, це був джекпот,
що можливість обмінятися з нашими
досвід
lidmilla зацікавила
Індонезію горизонтальними зв’язками,
горизонтальними
зв’язками, і в
радянські часи ми
взаємодіяли вертикально, а зараз ми
взаємодіємо горизонтально, і
гм,
цікаво, що ви думаєте,
гмм,
я вважаю, що всі ці горизонтальні
зв’язки зміцнюються загалом
і
що стосується проекту в цілому, він
привернув увагу професіоналів
багатьох професіоналів,
чому вони кажуть
важливим для мене, тому що ми живемо в
світі, коли всі змагаються за
чиюсь увагу, і я б
запросив вас прочитати пам’ять про статтю пана Бакарчука
та
гм
і Відродження подій, і
в тій самій статті він обговорював
такі явища, чим більше
уваги ви привернули до будь-якої проблеми, тим
швидше це питання починає розвиватися
[Музика]
хм
маленькі держави,
тим не менше, шановні колеги, матиме багато
проблем, які ми  потрібно розв’язати, а
тепер я задам запитання
про виклики,
гм, ви дуже специфічний регіон, який
зазнав багато втрат, або які
виклики ви бачите
для себе, е-е, для Міки,
ви всі знаєте,
гмм, перший виклик  це
відновити та відновити
пошкодження освітніх закладів
наступною проблемою є брак професіоналів,
е-е, професійних вчителів,
тому що ми конкуруємо з галуззю,
будь-який професійний кваліфікований
вчитель-інструктор може піти в
промисловий сектор і заробити набагато більше в
реальному регіоні, а
також
капітальні інвестиції  і е-е,
капітальні витрати є проблемою, тому що ми
знаходимося близько до лінії фронту,
а ще однією великою проблемою є те, що у
нас є три тисячі двісті
підприємств у регіоні, які
або пошкоджені, або зруйновані, і це,
звичайно, зменшує попит на робочу силу
та  професіонали, які
працюють професіонали,
але все ж ми залучили, як ви
правильно сказали, ми привернули увагу до
професійного навчання, але
проблеми є,
вони існують, і, звичайно, пізніше я
згадаю про дуальну освіту та е-е-е,
навчальні центри
е-е,
вони потребують матеріальної фінансової
підтримки від держави  тому що ми маємо
закупити для них нове обладнання,
на мій погляд, найбільші виклики для
професійного навчання та освіти полягають у
наступному. Проблема номер один,
професійні
вчителі
в системі професійного навчання. Друга проблема – це
кваліфіковане керівництво,
є багато дискусій, як які
вимоги до м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-м-мм академічно слухаємо тощо. Те саме стосується сектору
ветеринарної медицини, і третє завдання для ветеринарного сектору – це проблема дивіться конкретна мета професійного навчання для
середньої освіти полягає в тому, як гм
подолати байдужість
серед
учнів,
як
гм
підбадьоріть
ініціативу
та
амбіції
серед наших класів
про виклики найбільший виклик, який я
очікую стати
гмм
постом або відновленням України, і
це вимагатиме мобільності
Я вважаю, що це вимагатиме
зміни списку національних
робітничих професій,
важливих для  національному рівні,
тому що на регіональному рівні на даний момент
немає можливості виробляти
достатню кількість
фахівців, необхідних саме в цьому регіоні,
тоді як у сусідніх регіонах
в інших регіонах ці
працівники можуть знадобитися для розгляду,
а по-друге, як
хм,
як розробити стратегію, як відібрати
відповідних
кандидатів до наших закладів професійної підготовки,
тобто як вибрати між
академічними
відбірними студентами для академічних чи
дослідницьких установ для професійного
навчання,
і наступним завданням є
центри чи центри передового досвіду для  VT,
ми маємо створити лише один, щоб усі
інші, хто має сирні центри, могли зрозуміти,
якими мають бути належні центри передового досвіду.
Він має бути
добре обладнаним, він має бути
багатофункціональним, він має бути добре
оснащеним найкращим персоналом,
і ми
маємо платити достатньо
вчителям і таким навчальним центрам
не менше 30
000. Дохід сьогодні ми продовжуємо говорити, що 43
відсотки учнів середніх
шкіл вони обирають професійне навчання
для кар’єри, але як регіон ми
повинні чітко розуміти, що
для нас є привабливим  з точки зору
вбивств і попиту з боку ринку праці, коли
інвестори приходять до нас і кажуть, що ми маємо,
нам потрібні такі навички, і ми повинні мати
можливість
виробляти речі, і тут
дуже важлива законодавча база, ми повинні
дозволити регіонам дуже швидко змінюватись на
основі  щодо відповідного законодавства,
дякую, ви піднімаєте питання про
центри передового досвіду, і ви згадали про
позитивні моделі, для яких десь, я
думаю, у нас є такі центри
передового досвіду, я знаю принаймні один і,
можливо, ви також знаєте такі центри,
наскільки я  знаю програму
розвитку сектору VT живого регіону
вже затверджено і в тій програмі
навіть були зазначені певні суми грошей
я пам’ятаю що кілька років
тому була виділена перша субвенція
це було щось близько 50 мільйонів, а
зараз це сума яка виділяється
тільки для одного регіону для живого регіону,
цього року ми виділили до 10
мільйонів на професійне навчання, але
коли ми об’єднали всі
елементи цієї
системи, ми зрозуміли, що нам потрібно
ще 40 мільйонів, і
врешті-решт, коли ми виробляємо  в остаточному
плані нам виділили ще 13
мільйонів, це дивно,
нам пообіцяли отримати 53 мільйони
мрії зараз для розвитку
додаткових центрів VT в регіоні,
але вся ця маса грошей, це не
просто гм
[Музика]
цифра, але це було
хм, базуючись на дуже добре
розробленому плані, хм,
плані дій, спостерігати вдалося переконати
величезну кількість людей у
важливості сектору VT і, звичайно,
принципів наших установ IBT, вони
роблять великий внесок, а
система моніторингу та нагляду
розроблена не для покарання  він
призначений для
кращої підтримки
з 1 вересня, ми
розпочнемо
наш новий підхід, і я вірю, що до
грудня ми зможемо представити
автоматизовану систему для
сектору VHS у веб-області управління
гмм, у нас немає
нічого подібного  Регіон Лівія,
звичайно, ситуація в різних
регіонах, вона різна, і
ми не можемо в моїй співпраці, ми можемо мріяти
про дно
можливостей живого регіону, але,
незважаючи на це, наші плани планів
амбітні, і ми
знайшли в собі сміливість
розробити нашу власну стратегію та всі наші
установи  розробили свої
стратегії, і зараз ми завершуємо
ці стратегії до 2025 року,
я повністю згоден з патрулем, коли
він каже, що навички є валютою, і
в цьому контексті ми розуміємо, що лише 10
відсотків внутрішньо переміщених осіб з
регіону співпраці повернулися,
але  це ще раз говорить про те, що
мікронавички та мікрокваліфікація повинні
бути нашою першочерговою турботою,
це схоже на
ситуацію з бомбосховищами, які ми повинні
обладнати без будь-яких грошей, насправді
винайти, як це зробити
[Музика]
е-е,
іноді ми чуємо  що
деякі інновації, які вони не можуть або
не повинні бути впроваджені у сфері
ПТ, вони розроблені виключно для
середньої освіти, і в таких
ситуаціях ми почуваємося
[Музика]
е-е, розчаровані
наступним аспектом є психологічна
підтримка наших учнів
[Музика]
вперше за ці місяці ми проводимо
програму обміну,
тоді як цього літа ми відправляємо наших
студентів, які взяли Данська до
Морської технічної школи, яка є
дуже
професійною та дуже вимогливою з
технічної точки зору,
і
я вважаю, що це потрібно  ну,
щоб затвердити
правила,
які студенти можуть навчатися в
спеціальних групах, а не в інклюзивних групах, я маю
на увазі, ну, я маю на увазі студентів з
особливими потребами,
так, я з вами згоден, питання
інклюзії є досить складним питанням,
досить часто, учні з особливими
потребами  вони отримують медичну довідку про те, що
вони здатні з деякими функціональними
учнями з деякими функціональними
обмеженнями, вони отримують нам медичну
довідку про те, що вони здатні оволодіти
певною професією, але насправді вони
не можуть цього зробити, і
гм [
Музика]
гм ух
у
живому регіоні ух
тепер у нас є проблеми з цим, а також із
системою оподаткування, коли
податок із заробітної плати вираховується в регіоні та
залишається в регіоні, а потім, коли
військові, які сплачують цей податок,
повертаються в регіон, тоді ми можемо
задовольнити їхні  потреби в підготовці, якщо
говорити про військову службу,
ви знаєте, що західний
командувач має проблеми
з армією,
коли військовослужбовець повертається до
місцевих громад,
потрібні гроші на перепідготовку,
проблема із зворотними
позиками
виникає, коли ви отримуєте податок із зарплати
військові, які служать в армії, які
роблять великий внесок у податкові
надходження у вашому регіоні, це добре, але
коли вони повернуться, у вас виникнуть
проблеми з отриманням тих самих податкових
надходжень, ну,
наступний
спосіб вирішити це – регулярні зустрічі
з  підприємства Рівненської області, і
вони знайомлять нас зі своїми
проблемами,
гм, ми намагаємося зробити ці підприємства
легальними, щоб отримати кращі
податкові платежі, податкові надходження, і ми
розвиваємо кілька кластерів сільськогосподарський
кластер, лісовий кластер, тощо, що
це означає,
сільськогосподарський кластер  мова йде
не лише про вирощування
сільськогосподарської продукції, а й про
її сертифікацію для продажу. Це не
так просто, пам’ятаючи, що кожна
країна
прагне до вищої
конкурентоспроможності виробників сільськогосподарської
продукції.  дуже
важливо,
ми повинні мати на увазі, що бізнес
не повинен бути тільки великим бізнесом,
має бути малий і середній
бізнес, тому що в разі краху
великого бізнесу ви матимете великі
проблеми у вашому регіоні, тому вам
потрібен диверсифікований
бізнес, тобто  малий і
середній бізнес без такого
підходу, коли ви намагаєтеся підтримувати і
розвивати такі МСП, я проти
класифікації професій, яка
зараз існує, ми повинні привести нашу національну
структуру професій у відповідність до
європейської, в цьому випадку буде  вміти
належним чином організувати процес у цьому випадку ми матимемо
майбутнє. Дякую, ви
згадали про це, що
наших студентів потрібно навчати, як
створювати стартапи, як створювати компанії,
як стати менеджерами власного
бізнесу
Вікторія, у нас є  ми не забули про вас,
і ми раді, що ви з нами,
завдяки вашому досвіду роботи в проекті та
вашим знанням системи ветеринарної медицини,
що б ви порадили нашим місцевим
менеджерам, на
яких напрямках зосередитися,
щоб розвивати професійну
освіту в Україні,
все, що дороге вашому серцю
так, дякую,
кілька головних думок
щодо справжнього наближення шкіл
до роботодавців ще до війни, і
протягом війни
ми спостерігали досить динамічні зміни на
ринку праці та професіях, які були
актуальними до війни,
вони можуть втратити свою актуальність
цього разу
та  опитування проводиться серед
роботодавців, щоб дізнатися їхні потреби,
ви знаєте, що вони все ще не завжди допомагають
визначити їхні потреби, тому нам
потрібно просто зробити їх обох ближчими
також з точки зору підприємств, яким довелося
переїхати до Західної України,
на мій погляд, це  це досить важлива
тема, про яку не можна забувати чи випускати з уваги
кращі шини
з роботодавцями та освіченими підприємствами;
також дуже важливо та актуально
мати короткострокові курси також для
дорослих
для внутрішньо переміщених осіб,
тому що вже зараз і після війни
роботодавцям потрібна буде хороша кваліфікована
робоча сила
давайте не забувати про більшу групу
людей, які не зможуть продовжувати
працювати зі своїми власними
професіями з довоєнними професіями, і їм
доведеться
шукати нові навички, і через
це короткострокові курси будуть дуже
важливі
деякі з результатів проекту, як-от
знання, розробка інструментів,
було б приємно побачити їх впровадження
на практиці,
особливо як оцінювання на основі компетенції
та пов’язані теми, це
може спрацювати, це три речі,
які я хотів би
окреслити, дякую  дуже близький до
Вікторії,
я не дуже розумію, володимер, чи є
якісь запитання від онлайн-
аудиторії,
пам’ятайте, що ми пам’ятаємо про них в Інтернеті,
і якщо є запитання, то, очевидно, жодних
питань, добре
[Музика],
можливо, у нас є запитання чи коментарі з
залу, і ми  дивіться іноді рука від
Діри, у вас є загальне чи конкретне
запитання, гаразд, нехай вони всі
над цим попотіють,
вибачте, тут Майк,
мені потрібно більше рухатися, дякую,
дякую за цю
справді досить цікаву панельну
дискусію, е-е, доповнює бензин на
національному регіональному рівні, е-е  добре
сприймається, і баланс
також сприймається. У мене є наступне запитання, я сподіваюся, ви
пам’ятаєте, коли ми
кілька років тому, чи
добре, всі хотіли провести аудит, і ми
також це зробили, ми хотіли оптимізувати ветеринарну
систему
відразу після аудиторії,
потім минув час
і  коли було прийнято відповідне рішення,
ситуація змінилася,
тож яке ваше бачення
відновлення, це стосується Люка
Міллера, що ви думаєте про відновлення
руїн ветеринарних шкіл, чи вважаєте ви, що
кожну кімнату в цій школі потрібно
відновити, я ні  розумійте людський
аспект цього, але все ж ви вважаєте, що
потрібно відновити кожну ветеринарну школу, чи слід
приділити більшу увагу?
Так, я маю на увазі заклад професійної
освіти та навчання,
я не говорю про
середні школи чи щось подібне,
тому перш за все моє запитання  звертається до Людмили
та, можливо, меншою мірою до інших.
Це стосується фактичної оптимізації,
зокрема, у мене друге
запитання до Петра, ти законодавець моди,
шановний Петро, ​​тебе визнали
таким, добре, коли говорити про кластери,
це про ти знаєш  щось на кшталт
розумної спеціалізації, тому що я думаю, що ви
були пілотом, не спроможним
розробити відповідну стратегію, було б
добре
почути про це від вас з точки зору обміну досвідом, а також з
огляду на майбутні навички для
проекту відновлення, які ми хотіли б  щоб почути
від вас деяку думку, тому чекаю короткі відповіді,
шановні учасники дискусії,
якщо виникнуть додаткові запитання.
Гаразд, що стосується оптимізації, ми
розпочали процес створення безжиттєвих
ще у 2020 році, у
нас була робоча група, я та учасники,
і ми працювали над цим із великою кількістю наших
колег
з 31 медучилища ми вирішили залишитися
з 22.
Статистично ми все ще маємо приблизно 31
бота де-факто,
ми продовжили це
минулого року, у нас було реорганізовано дві конституції,
і ми продовжуємо це цього
року.
Отже, якщо говорити про заклад, який
був  зруйнована, знищена або пошкоджена, у
нас є одна школа, яка все
ще висить,
це також передбачає матеріально-технічне
забезпечення, тому ми розглядаємо, що
на даний момент ми повинні вирішити, чи буде у
нас ця погана школа,
чи можливо її зберегти, щоб
відновити
решта ветеринарних шкіл, які залишилися,
навіть якщо їх буде пошкоджено, вони підлягатимуть
відновленню та реконструкції. Так,
знадобиться багато грошей, але
знову ж таки ми продовжуємо наш
процес оптимізації, тож лише одна, яка є
крутою, зі знаком питання,
добре, дякую, і перш ніж Петро
відповість
ну так, враховуючи рівень Обеліска, я
думаю, що це не єдиний навчальний заклад
у Мексиці, чи
благословення, що у
нас немає жодної
ветеринарної школи з менш ніж 300 студентами,
тому у нас є набагато більше таких шкіл у
Vivo, тому це складне питання
для топлес  але повертаючись до
кластерів,
так, ми зрозуміли це на ранній стадії, що
без розумної спеціалізації без
передових цифрових і технологічних консультацій у
нас не буде достатньо фінансових ресурсів для
Обеліска, і ми пішли цим шляхом і
вийшли за межі Обеліска, насправді,
знаєте, е-е  компанія mtac, яку
вони надають, близька навіть до
президента, і ми познайомили їх із
decadelipska
матеріалом, який використовує виробник тканини,
таким чином компанія
дійсно створила можливість уникнути
важливості дешевих зусиль з
Китаю, вони можуть робити все на місці
або ми  Раніше було таке інституційне
протистояння між професійною, е-е, різновидом
запрошеної освіти та навчання та
державною службою зайнятості,
наприкінці цього уряд втратив
кожного свого колегу, який хотів купити
обладнання.
Фінансові ресурси,
і,
здається, ми кращі у
викладанні та службі зайнятості  ми
кращі в пошуку людей, тому
нам потрібно переосмислити всю структуру,
це призведе до абсолютно іншого
технологічного
рівня для всього обеліска,
тому неможливо мати лише одну
компанію, яка буде робити
все, що це буде неможливо  але ви
можете мати комбінацію компаній, які
спеціалізуються на власних процесах,
щоб ви знали, скажімо, з точки зору обробки тексту, у
нас є субпідрядник або контракт на
виробництво піддонів, який користується великим
попитом і який може прийняти участь,
оскільки він може виконати цю частину роботи  і
вони можуть заробляти, вони будуть
релевантними, це позитивний імідж,
і якщо ми знову почнемо
навчання впродовж усього життя, потрібно
буде зрозуміти,
як краще залучити систему подій,
оскільки просто приватно-державне партнерство
недостатньо, нам потрібно об’єднати зусилля
вартість навчання у ветеринарній школі
має бути достатньо високою,
якщо ви хочете мати таку рівність,
і для цього нам не потрібні
сендвіч-школи з 300 студентами кожна,
нам потрібна одна велика з 3000 із них,
і я бачу, у нас є запитання.  у
мене є запитання до Вікторії,
ви згадали про систему оцінювання,
як ви ставитесь до поточної
системи оцінювання прогресу з
балом 12 як до архаїчної системи,
і
чи влаштовує вас
встановлення вікна у вашому домі з
оцінками, що відповідають скажімо рівню  шість сім
п’ять, можливо,
дякую за запитання. Я вважаю, що
оцінювання має базуватися на компетентності,
коли ми говоримо про ветеринарів.
Теорія – це добре, але має бути певне
підтвердження, практичне підтвердження
навичок і знань,
і я б справді зосередився на тому, що
не Юрій ядерний, можливо, Юлій  капуста,
це дуже сказати щось,
якщо так, просто візьміть мікрофон
Casio з nka
насправді
бензин
згадував nkf кілька разів, я не
впевнений, чи ви це помітили, але я дуже
чутливий до теми,
тому Пабло та Петро вони говорять про
професіоналізм
професійна освіта та
підготовка, тому моє запитання полягає в тому, що
професійна та професійна освіта
та підготовка є синонімами чи ні,
а інше запитання звідси є
nkf з різними
рівнями підготовки, тому професійна чи
професійна освіта та підготовка, які там
рівні, як  вони відповідають тому, як
ми можемо порівняти з Європою та
світом,
гаразд, бензин, з якого ви, мабуть, не хочете
починати,
ми говоримо про
професійну освіту, ось як я
хотів би, щоб це було,
і я думаю, що такі рівні, як три
чотири п’ять  здебільшого про наш
внутрішній
раз, і для Річа круто
вирішувати, який рівень вони збираються
вивчати. ​​Не думаю, що кожен має
готуватися до різних рівнів, деякі можуть
тренуватися лише на третьому рівні, інші,
можливо, на третьому, четвертому, четвертому чи п’ятому рівнях
моя ідея полягає в тому, що ми не повинні дозволяти
студентам сидіти там, доки вчителі не
отримають кількість годин і не отримають свою
зарплату
з точки зору особистої освіти або вищої
професійної освіти. Я вважаю, що
найважливіше полягає в тому, що нам потрібно мати
унікальний єдиний тип  інституція, як,
можливо, професійно-технічний коледж, це допоможе
нам сформулювати це перед громадськістю, тому
нам потрібно сказати людям, що так, у нас є
професійний коледж
для цієї професії або цих професій,
я сподіваюся, що зможу прожити достатньо довго, щоб
побачити, як
все буде добре, ще є запитання
лише одне за одним прямо
під час перерви,
тож лише одне запитання від кожного. Лише
представники Європейської комісії мають
право мати два
[Музика]
ну так, мені дуже сподобалося те, що Петро
згадав, вибачте, що у нас цього не було,
або не було  це тут, але
знову ж таки, диявол криється в деталях, наскільки велика
проблема, щоб вирішити проблему, коли для третього та
четвертого рівнів ми навчаємо професій, тоді у нас є
спеціальна поїздка для п’ятого рівня, як ми можемо
інтегрувати це в одну систему освіти,
я б не робив цього законодавчо  через законодавчий акт
я пропоную, що є можливість,
згадана в законі, а потім підзаконні акти
повинні вказати це
icmps
активні будь-що прокоментувати від
вас
ні гаразд, у нас
закінчується час, тому
запитання, будь ласка,
якщо більше немає запитань,
дозвольте нам заново  Панельне обговорення, і ми
розпочнемо з оплесків
нашим прекрасним учасницям
із захоплюючими промовами,
ми бачимо, що система ветеринарної медицини
впевнено утримується
некомпетентною людиною, тому
щодо вашої Віри ми віримо,
що все продовжуватиметься,
і
з нашої розмови з  Сергій Бабак,
ми чули, що перемога прийде тоді, коли
ми зможемо повернути всіх наших дітей
назад в Україну, і це справді
дуже важлива тема, нам потрібно, щоб наші
люди повернулися, щоб вони повернулися,
і я бачу, що дискусія призвела до
багато тем,
над якими слід поміркувати нашим членам парламенту,
було б приємно побачити принаймні 230
голосів за це,
а потім було згадано, що
слід уникати фрагментації між містами та сільськими районами, тому що
також на різних рівнях Райан  рівні
безнадійний рівень і
статус магістрів освіти
професійної освіти має бути якось
закріплено в законі повинні
бути певні міри, які ви знаєте,
щоб співвіднести
свій досвід і здатність змусити
їх гідно заробляти гроші,
тому що вони мають на це право,
я думаю, враховуючи, що ми  майте
з нами aeroshromic, ви створюєте сильну команду, вони
точно проживуть достатньо довго, щоб побачити
ці зміни,
дякую, всі
дивуються
закордонна
цифровізація та її роль у
розвитку
учасників vit IA Я радий вітати вас
на нашій сесії номер три,
дозвольте нам  Почніть,
Ед,
давайте почнемо з деяких
організаційних питань.
Я поміркований у нашій сьогоднішній сесії, мене
звуть Анна Саходзкам,
і я хотів би почати з
чудових
організаційних моментів, у нас буде
дві частини нашої сесії, перша частина
буде присвячена
інноваційні рішення, а друга частина
майбутньому, планам на майбутнє, тож давайте
почнемо з
оцифрування, е-е, попереднього налаштування
[Музика],
хм,
як воно проникає в сектори
освіти, і ми подивимося на
оцифрування з адміністративної
з точки зору методології та з
точки зору практичного впровадження,
і пам’ятаючи про це, я хотів би
запросити наших учасників дискусії,
тому наші учасники панелі пан Алексіс Сідней,
старший менеджер проекту
з Міністерства освіти та
науки, ну, команда підтримки,
і він також належить до  дирекція
VT
тоді у нас є пан Андрій Літвін chocohost
перший заступник директора державної
наукової установи Інститут
освіти та аналітики
разом із садівником
або вони працюють над спільним проектом garna
знаходиться під хоспісом Міністерства
освіти Естонії
назад іноземний
заступник  директор освітньо-
методичного центру VT у
регіоні live natala розробила 11
інтерактивних
навчальних курсів для National на
платформі live pro,
тоді у нас є Даша Ягіна, національний
експерт з ed ufi
[Оплески]
ну,
який баланс
у старому просторі Фінляндії  міністра
освіти, і вона працювала над
завершенням завершеного компоненту нашого
проекту, а потім у нас не було
вчителя кетчуку з міжрегіональної школи Vanessa Inter Regional
habitous School,
яка входить
до нашої першої сотні найкращих
навчальних закладів професійного навчання в Україні, а
їх
спеціалізацією є цифрове навчання
як я вже згадував,
оцифрування стало невід’ємною частиною
освіти, і завдяки нашому
проекту ЄС для навичок, партнерів,
гм,
ми
запровадили багато цікавих інтерактивних
навчальних курсів приблизно два тижні тому
у Viva у
нас була конференція про
запровадження ETI над Alexi
описав нові цифрові
інструменти для VT
[Музика]
хм,
як ви думаєте, які найефективніші
найкорисніші рішення,
прийняті міністерством у сфері
цифровізації, я буду вдячний вам за це
запитання,
я хотів би почати з нашого найбільшого
досягнення Я трохи хвилююся сьогодні, і
єдиний
фактор, який мене втішає, це те, що я бачу багато
знайомих облич сьогодні в залі, і
коли ти на великій
сцені,
і ця подія транслюється, я завжди
починаю вітати з днем ​​народження
та  Я радий
привітати пізню подію, тому що
перед відділом v80
[Музика]
веб-регіональної
адміністрації мої найкращі побажання Івон
за його підтримку, яка
підтримує оцифровку v18 у реальному
регіоні, і зараз я почну своє
втручання,
я вважаю, три найкращі
проекти  про що
я хотів би згадати в контексті
цифровізації з 1 липня
випускники наших шкіл
отримають
атестати,
і ми почнемо думати про подальшу
освіту,
і на цьому етапі цього року ми
надали їм можливість подавати
атестати в електронному вигляді.
мої естонські колеги, такі як проект Amis,
Андреа,
опишуть більше цей різноманітний естонський
компонент нашого
проекту, а третій
– це онлайн-платформа професійного навчання,
хм,
на самому початку у нас було лише 29
курсів професійного навчання на цій
платформі, але
ми працювали і працювали,
сьогодні у нас є, у
нас є набагато більше, ми навіть присвятили
всю позицію матеріалам, які потрібно
опублікувати на цій платформі, на сьогодні у
нас є 80 курсів на цій платформі,
отже, між
груднем, коли ми почали з
певних дев’яти, і тепер ми  у мене більше
80, а до кінця цього року я
матиму близько 100, схоже, цього
недостатньо проти потреби 300 різних
професій, але,
насправді, 100 — це занадто багато. Тож моя відповідь
: електронна подача
документів для вступу, пані, та онлайн
платформа для курсів,
які можливості надає оцифрування
для управління та
адміністрування системи ветеринарної медицини, це
моє друге запитання,
для
VT,
це
дистанційне
навчання на OBT дуже корисне для
тих, хто втік, хто втік
за кордон, і
наші
студенти не можуть отримати таку ж
освіту за кордоном безкоштовно, а
наша платформа надає безкоштовний доступ до
найсучасніших навчальних матеріалів.
хм,
це базується на
належній інформації, належній якісній
інформації, вчора,
обговорюючи
подальший розвиток цього проекту,
ми обговорювали
різні типи інформаційних панелей для
міністерств для
ммм
освітніх регіональних
управлінь освіти тощо,
і
тому пані на керівному рівні та
електронний вхід до
Навчальні заклади VT є важливими,
оскільки вони показують цілісну картину
абітурієнтам і дозволяють
правильно вибрати те, що вони хочуть,
і це дозволяє нам пропонувати
якомога повніше
для всіх рівнів
Алексі кілька разів згадував про
Амоса, чи могли б ви описати, як
система MSR  було розроблено крок за кроком і
як це було реалізовано
чи були у вас труднощі будь-які
ризики, особливо пов’язані із
захистом персональних даних Я Андреа перший заступник
директора
державної наукової установи Інститут
аналітики освіти
ми
збираємо ці адміністративні звіти,
аналізуємо їх і готуємо
[Музика]
деякі висновки для управління, заснованого на доказах, у
будь-якому випадку
ми обговорюємо команду, ми
з’ясовуємо, що
цифровізація
[Музика]
у VTS почалася
з вищої освіти, ніж
[Музика]
гм
у початковій освіті, і врешті-решт вона
досягла сектору професійного навчання,
і
це призвело до
гм поява
гмм
повної комплексної бази даних
тоді
ми маємо хм історичну серію звітів, які
регулярно подають навчальні
заклади деякі хм індикатори і
ці звіти деякі елементи в них вони
трохи застарілі хм
[Музика]
гм,
які не можна було використовувати для
оцифрування  обробка, так би мовити,
завдання
полягало в тому, щоб
об’єднати ці дві потреби, щоб
об’єднати
все це в систему Ms, щоб
зібрати дані з описових звітів,
агрегувати їх на національному рівні, е-е,
і об’єднати
дані про
студентів і про тих, хто надає
освіту та послуги,
коли  ми підходимо до того, що персональні
дані надходять у
державну систему даних, і особливо в
умовах воєнного стану
ми отримуємо величезні багаторазові ризики, і
ми розуміємо,
що ми можемо бути об’єктами
кіберзлочинців у кіберзлочинців
наших
ворогів, але
гм
чим агресивнішими є наші вороги,
тим сильнішими ми стаємо в результаті
протидії, і тепер ми створили
багаторівневу
систему захисту,
яка
має ті ж елементи L, що
існували на національному
рівні,
і базується на комплексній системі
захисту інформації,
таким чином  ми готові
пом’якшити найбільші ризики,
гм команда, яка працювала над реалізацією проекту
Об’єднані
експерти міністерства зі
структурних підрозділів міністерства також
естонська сторона і мені дуже подобається те, що
зробив Алексі,
і згадав про свого друга, я хотів би
скористатися цією можливістю  подякувати Харнеру
нашим естонським колегам
Raul uh
crop group
і tejana
Sergey.
Ця велика команда
працювала
над системою,
щоб запобігти тому, щоб система працювала у
вакуумі без жодного зв’язку з
навколишнім
середовищем.
Ця команда працювала над екологічним
продуктом, щоб  зробити систему якомога більш
однорідною зробити
модельєра системи це система Icom
і відповідає цій пісні
2.0 [
Музика]
це
системи управління освітою, які вже
впроваджені на практиці
завершуючи своє втручання Я хотів би
згадати ці кіберзагрози  і навіть
технічні
перешкоди для вашої дитини, щоб досягти
міжопераційного
зв’язку між різними
ресурсами, досить часто ви стикаєтеся з багатьма
складними труднощами сумісність
протоколів це завжди проблема,
і нам довелося подолати багато
проблем,
тому ми зробили все, що
зараз дозвольте  наш
підхід до регіонального рівня спустіться
з національного рівня на регіональний.
Наталя, можливо, ви почнете
з привітання вашої колекції, покиньте
регіон,
а тепер моє запитання
до вас ой,
де успішно, ну, рішення у
сфері цифровізації ну з з
з  з освітньої точки зору, дякую,
сьогодні ми обговорюємо,
ви знаєте, потужні інструменти цифровізації,
і я пам’ятаю, що станом на 2019–2020 роки
до 50 відсотків нашого
педагогічного персоналу
не мали навіть базових навичок у
сфері цифровізації, як
створити свій  обліковий запис електронної пошти, як працювати
з iCloud, і
це
була проблема:
деякі працівники
не могли працювати в цифровому
середовищі,
тоді як студенти, яких навчають ці вчителі,
вони набагато краще
знайомі з цифровими технологіями,
тому спочатку нам довелося  переконати таких людей у ​​тому,
що їм потрібно знати
цифрову
грамотність, і для
цього знадобилося багато зусиль за
кордоном,
щоб зробити цей прорив на вищий
рівень.
Я дуже вдячний нашим партнерам з
ЄС за навички, ніж вони  дозволило нам досягти
цих рівнів і організувати курси
зі створення медіа-контенту та
показати людям, що можна
зробити та наскільки це корисно, таким чином наш
навчальний персонал тепер може створювати
відеоконтент з навчальними матеріалами для
створення
каналів YouTube і
о
До речі,
зараз ми маємо такий факт, що освітній
контент, створений майстром
професійної підготовки перукарів, дуже
попит на YouTube,
оскільки ми опанували
виробництво візуальних
матеріалів VT, ми відчули, що готові створювати
ширші
курси VT, і коли Юрій подзвонив мені  і
поставив запитання, чи готові ви
розпочати це, е-е,
і ми почали працювати над вмістом,
наші плани були досить амбітними, і
е-е, хоча ми думали, що повністю
готові, але дуже скоро ми з’ясували, що
створення
оцифрованого контенту VT значно більше
відрізняється від  просто
проходити заняття та навчати студентів у
класі,
гм,
навчальний онлайн-курс дуже відрізняється
від офлайн-класу, там повинні бути інші
матеріали, його слід адаптувати, це потрібно
робити швидко та
іншим способом, тому нам довелося навчитися
робити якісні  фотографії короткі
відео як розробити тести
та зробивши перші кроки, ми запропонували
ширші матеріали для ширшої аудиторії,
яка не лише для студентів, але й
для
вчителів або навіть для широкої
громадськості, наприклад [
Музика]
тих людей, тих широких кіл, які
зацікавлені в секторі Hurricane,
вони можуть піти на наші навчальні курси та
розповісти, що контент організований таким
чином, що ви можете стежити за успіхами
студента,
тому вдячні всій команді
та підтримці навичок eu4, дякую,
Наталія,
так  це була справді ретельна робота над
розробкою онлайн-контенту,
і на платформу вже завантажено понад 17 лінійних курсів,
так, Алексі, будь ласка,
лише кілька зауважень.
Наталія почала з того, що
сказала щось у тому, що ти знаєш, щось
стримане,
бо вони не знали, як  зареєструвати
адресу електронної пошти тощо, я не знаю, але
коли я почав з вами спілкуватися,
ви вже все знали,
і, як сказав Пабло,
добре, я був більш уважним до
апаратного компоненту, але знову ж таки компоненти програмного забезпечення
були досить великими,
і тепер я бачу  як люди ростуть,
у свою чергу, ми піддамо їх
додатковим тестам, щоб виявити потенційні
прогалини,
і ми збираємося зробити це справді
індивідуально,
щоб задовольнити індивідуальні потреби
щодо цього в Інтернеті, я рішуче підтримую, не
могли б ви поділитися браузером  екран,
просто напишіть професору Світі Дот онлайн,
так, це чудова нагода
просувати нашу платформу,
платформу, яку ми розробили в
рамках навичок u4,
яку можуть використовувати не лише
Шукачі
професійного навчання, але й мої
вчителі idps  інші зацікавлені сторони
[Музика]
поки що нічого не бачать на екрані,
але, можливо, це буде привабливим для пізнього запуску,
якщо його можна опустити трохи вниз, щоб
люди просто бачили кількість
професій,
професійні категорії, і ви заходите туди,
щоб знайти онлайн-курси, які можете  пройдіть
цей тренінг, навчаючись самостійно, коли вам
зручно, ви можете використовувати його
для читання
лекцій для
підвищення кваліфікації, завдяки чому
ви можете зробити свій власний
навчальний заклад привабливішим, і для
цього,
так,
потрібна лише
реєстрація як викладача чи
студента
та решту 30 секунд  пройти
навчальний курс згадує Наталія Юрій
Зубан у рамках
програми молодіжних навичок, вони найкращі за якістю, там
є симулятори, які
вбудовані в
додатки
з доповненою реальністю, і ви
берете участь у цьому навчальному курсі,
тоді  Ви можете відсканувати QR-код на своєму
телефоні, щоб виконати тест. Погана новина
для вас полягає в тому, що ми почали розробляти
новий набір навчальних курсів,
використовуючи послуги іншого
субпідрядника, і я не збираюся
розголошувати назву, а результат  буде
ще краще, тому ми ростемо, і вам доведеться
рости разом з нами,
дякую, Лексі, ви знаєте, що розум
переходить до
Росії, вона
представлятиме наших
фінських колег і результати,
тому вони додали, які
найбільш перспективні та кращі результати
замість  оцифрування
професійно-технічної освіти та навчання так,
доброго дня, просто щоб розповісти вам більше
про те, що ми зробили в рамках Консорціуму 12
о, ми
розробили набір курсів під назвою «
Відбудова України», у нас є
навчальна програма для
керівників ветеринарних шкіл, і у нас є
онлайн  програма для вчителів
[Музика]
просто щоб розповісти про мету, яку ми ставили
під час розробки цього курсу,
ми мали на меті забезпечити підтримку
їх розвитку або професійних
компетенцій
у ветеринарній системі заради
відновлення вашого крана,
що стосується тренінгів для адміністраторів
та вчителів,
це було зроблено  щоб просувати цю реформу та
справді допомагати адміністраторам і
вчителям здобувати нові
навички та компетенції, у
нас було зареєстровано понад 19
000 учасників для навчання
та понад 12,5 000 сертифікатів, які
ми мали для тих, хто пройшов або модулі, або навчальний курс.
після цього подивіться тест, щоб отримати сертифікат,
і ці навчальні програми курси та
модулі деякі з них були популярнішими,
ніж інші п’ятірка найкращих – це
перша допомога
досить актуальна зараз, тоді як
піклуватися про дітей у кризовій
ситуації та сприяти
благополуччю сім’ї  -
так,
ще одна тропічна тема про роботу на
будівництві
та програму навчання менеджера, добре, дякую,
Даша,
дорога Хана, ми не забули про
тебе.
Тож з педагогічної точки зору,
які найефективніші рішення у
сфері цифровізації,
деякі з них, ймовірно, реалізовано  або
ви, можливо, маєте намір їх реалізувати, я
знаю, що
як викладач ви самі можете надати нам
детальну відповідь,
доброго дня,
я представляю іншу специфіку,
це круто,
тому що ми
навчаємо е-
е,
ми навчаємо спеціалістів у секторі 480,
насправді
ми
були впроваджені  ІКТ протягом досить тривалого
часу
навіть до проекту
і до того, коли у нас було достатньо
обладнання, але ви не розумієте, що
воно має тенденцію застарівати з часом
технічно
морально, якщо ви хочете,
і завдяки програмі,
насправді, що нам знадобиться, це
краща підтримка  що стосується технічного обладнання,
я маю на увазі цифрове обладнання, а не лише PCS,
але є різноманітне обладнання, яке
можна широко використовувати,
і ми отримали його досить багато в
рамках проекту,
ми брали участь у низці
програм, у нас є певні досягнення, якими можна
пишатися  і протягом
майже чотирьох років
наша ветеринарна школа
суттєво оновила свій
парк цифрового обладнання,
оскільки ми говоримо про
цифровізацію ветеринарних закладів.
Я б поставив пріоритет на перевірку
належного технічного обладнання Апаратне забезпечення,
потім необхідно вдосконалити
навички програмного забезпечення, а потім  те ж саме щодо
викладання,
і ми мали низку навчальних курсів,
які ми відвідали в рамках проекту та в
рамках проекту,
багато курсів спрямовані на вдосконалення
навичок ІТ, уміння використовувати та створювати цифровий
контент, працювати з відео тощо, і
це  Було б добре мати кілька
навчальних курсів,
як ви знаєте, Алексі згадав про необхідність
індивідуальної роботи з ветеринарними школами, і
враховуючи тип обладнання, яке ми маємо, як-от
відеокамери та 3D-принтери тощо,
нас ніколи не навчали правильно
використовувати їх, і ми  Ми використовували їх методом
проб і помилок, і,
мабуть, це не найефективніший
спосіб зробити це,
тому було б непогано пройти деякий
тренінг щодо використання цього найсучаснішого
обладнання,
і, по-третє,
дизайн і розробка цієї
Національної платформи професійної освіти
стали
Ви знаєте, це
серйозний сигнал для нас, потужна
допомога
в забезпеченні кращої участі нашого
викладацького складу в оцифрованому
навчанні.
Люди тепер краще звикли
використовувати ІКТ
[музику],
і ми б дуже хотіли, щоб
ця платформа розвивалася ще швидше, нам
це так подобається вам  не розумію,
що для створення контенту потрібен час,
і за цим повинні стояти деякі люди,
але все ж ми дуже
підтримуємо ідею запропонувати нам якомога більше
курсів, ми
все ще покладаємо великі надії на
платформу,
це безкоштовний доступ до  велика кількість
матеріалів для викладацького складу для
студентів
справді покращує якість навчання
та освіти
так, дякую, дякую, Йоганно,
ви навіть зазирнули в майбутнє, і
це стало гарним переходом до нашої
наступної дискусії,
яка стосуватиметься наступних кроків цифровізації
та різних точок зору на ці
та  Я б радше дав мікрофон Алексі,
щоб почути адміністративні аспекти
подальшої цифровізації
у сфері управління та
адміністрування, будь ласка,
тому давайте подумаємо не про
адміністративні аспекти, а у відповідь
на запит ваших колег,
ви знаєте, я чув нещодавні
коментарі про
потрібно мати якомога більше матеріалів
уже зараз,
як з цим впоратися, ви знаєте,
я обіцяю своїм колегам протягом
добрих півроку про медіа-лабораторії, які будуть
організовані в окремих регіонах,
щоб дозволити
вчителям самостійно працювати над
своїм власним
і  вчора я отримав підтвердження, що
проект щодо цього буде запущено,
тому, дорогі колеги, ми маємо
разом створювати освітній контент,
це те, що стосується розвитку їхньої платформи
щодо цифровізації
в адміністративній сфері, так,
і вони можуть мати більше про пані, я намагаюся
подумайте голосно,
дозвольте зробити це так,
вступ практично
повністю реалізовано, ми збираємося провести
великий вебінар завтра о 10.
Усі
адміністратори цих шкіл і
члени відбіркових комісій у
ветеринарних школах проведуть великий
вебінар про
електронне зарахування до цих шкіл
разом з harno
ми почуємо, як працювати з модулями
і так далі, у
нас уже є великий
пакет заходів тут Марк на
наступний рік один із більших кроків стосуватиметься
змін у
процедурі вступу
кілька сценаріїв буде  працював над тим, щоб
контролювати процес,
керувати всім, щоб побачити, скільки
заявок
надійшло та які професії
зросли, чи є найбільший попит і так
далі,
а
тепер про наступні кроки на етапі
розвитку Ms, і я думаю, що Андрій може розповісти про
це більше,
так, не могли б ви  будь ласка, розкажіть нам більше про
наступні етапи
розвитку MS um, як це буде
впроваджено на регіональному рівні, і
деякі з найбільш гострих питань: питання про
фінансування, оскільки
проект MS був підтриманий ЄС для навичок,
і питання, як це буде відбуватися
профінансовано пізніше,
гаразд, з вашого дозволу, я почну
з ширшого опису, а потім перейду
до конкретного питання,
перш за все, що стосується цифровізації
цього
управління,
є певні тенденції, які, здається,
узгоджуються з тим, що ми бачили
в усьому світі
маємо команду цифровізації, яка працює
з міністерством у сфері цифрової
трансформації, і ми бачимо, що
впроваджується більше інструментів
з точки зору бізнес-аналітики, щоб
уможливити обробку
серій великих даних,
особливо для людей, які
не дуже добре розбираються в
моделюванні на основі великої вибірки
тож буде цілий набір
індикаторів множників
і так далі, структурованих навколо певних
параметрів цифрового оцифрування, і
вони будуть доступні через браузер,
оскільки на
основі даних і гусей
показують, що це буде корисно для територій, на
яких ведуться неактивні військові дії або
вони спостерігалися останнім часом.
буде мати відношення до
адміністративно-територіальних одиниць
всі ці речі
важко активно впроваджувати
пілотувати в деяких випадках навіть уже використовувати
декілька доповідачів до мене зауважили, що,
на жаль,
ми повинні визнати,
що війна відкрила
для нас певні можливості, яких ми ніколи
раніше не мали, і це  дуже важливо
добре використовувати такі можливості, щоб не
втратити,
і тепер у нас є потужний набір інструментів,
наданий нашими партнерами в Інтернеті,
і це відкриває коридори в Avenues
для використання продуктів для нас.
Це не лише
загальновідомі речі, як ті, що
на  Google Microsoft
потенційно може побачити більш серйозні
речі, як-от використання штучного інтелекту або експериментальних,
і я думаю, що тепер державна
аналітика публічної аналітики навіть більш
спроможна, ніж раніше,
є певні конкретні аспекти,
пов’язані, скажімо, з конфіденційністю даних,
а не з кожною частиною інформації  можуть бути
представлені
у вільно доступних форматах,
а дезагреговані масивні серії даних
є обов’язковими, і
всі розуміють, що
міністерство вже давно
використовує це для реальних ситуацій.
Пабло, який справді повернув
субвенцію на освітню субвенцію
[Музика]
з належним розподілом розподіл
грошових потоків
від верху до низу з логістичною
моделлю, заснованою на
невеликих даних,
ви знаєте, кожного разу, коли я згадую якийсь
складний алгоритм розподілу, я випадково
думаю про Пабло, я пам’ятаю, я
пам’ятаю, як нам довелося
розділити набори Lego,
ми повинні були це вирішити, і це
не було  бути реальним і/або можливим за допомогою старих
гм
існуючих інструментів лише невеликі детальні дані,
надані можливість робити це в
умовах воєнного часу мова
йде про
подвійне введення інформації про
учнів, коли вони переходять між школами,
усі ці речі
тепер можливі завдяки
цифровізації та аналітиці
шлях вперед у плані подальшого
розвитку цих інструментів
включає взаємодію з іншими
загальнодоступними
системами управління [музикою] інформацією тощо,
тому що багато разів ми бачимо, що
інформація збирається
різними установами, і це той
самий тип інформації,
що означає величезні витрати  ресурсу,
завдяки цій сумісності
ми можемо покращити
чистоту даних,
ми можемо перевіряти валідацію,
тож чим далі ми йдемо, тим
більше
буде отримано,
а шина взаємодії з громадськістю,
яка називається termbita, з’єднує
кожну частину державної
системи управління інформацією,
і ми  вже бачать деякі
перспективні контакти, які
говорять про автоматизацію
процесу управління освітою,
оскільки
алгоритм реалізації
повністю зрозумілий, буде
підготовка тренерів,
будуть справді м’яко розроблені
та можуть бути впроваджені бороди
з хорошим розумінням того, що щось
додане
стосується додаткової інформації  це не
заміна старої інформації,
тому якщо
в систему буде введено велику кількість інформації, її
не буде скопійовано, щоб зробити іншу її частину,
її буде просто
замінено,
а збір даних здійснюватиметься не
лише за допомогою відомих вам електронних таблиць Excel
і каскадний спосіб, але мова йде про
створення
спільної національної системи управління інформацією
за кордоном,
і ці функції будуть розвиватися лише далі
щодо
підтримки модернізації системи розвитку майбутніх операцій,
оскільки
концепція системи buy it com con con,
яка була негайно схвалена
міністерством, тому  це стане модулем
два модуля вже існуючої та
вже впровадженої системи значків,
і це змусить його органічно відчути себе
в
програмах і бюджетних розкладах від
уряду. Немає необхідності
винаходити щось кардинально нове,
я думаю,
було б природним інтегрувати це в
доступні коридори
та
планувати
все наперед,
як у класичному прикладі, коли
розглядається національна програма цифровізації,
тож я вважаю, що всі ці речі досить
стійкі, а передача програмного забезпечення
здійснювалася належним чином. Жодних ризиків
щодо неповного
поглинання
права власності все було
повністю передано на основі «як є»,
тому, маючи загальне розуміння
апаратної
основи
програми,
ми вже
розвиваємо наше розуміння того, як
завершити й покращити її
[Музика]
дозвольте нам дотримуватися нашого обмеження часу,
дякую, Андреа,
дякую за
хм повне і повне втручання ми
кілька разів ви згадували про
штучний інтелект, я думаю, ми
можемо обговорити це з педагогічної точки
зору,
що
ви можете сказати собі як
представник фінського компоненту,
але нові
оцифровані компоненти та освіта,
чи можете ви згадати, що
е-е, доповнена реальність зі штучним інтелектом
може сприяти
розвитку освіти. Я вважаю, що
тимчасова освіта, яку вони постійно вдосконалюють,
е-е,
доповнена реальність зі штучним інтелектом
доповнила реальність, і все, що
я хотів би згадати наступне,
як симуляцію, моделювання можна
використовувати в освіті.  захоплюючий
економічний ефективний вони
вражаючі, але
вони не роблять, коли ви тренуєте учнів на
тренажері, це зменшує ризики, у
вас є необмежена кількість
спроб, е-е, один
учень у 3D-окулярах,
тоді вони можуть отримати миттєвий зворотний зв’язок
від
викладача, навчаючись і як виправити
їхні помилки, це теж досить дешевий
варіант, або ви можете зробити навчання
стійким, економічно життєздатним і хм
[Музика]
тепер студенти деяких спеціальностей
не можуть отримати доступ до критичної
інфраструктури, а
навчання на симуляторах дозволяє їм
отримати це з точки зору метавсесвіту
view
має потенціал для трансформації дистанційного
навчання, щоб об’єднати вчителів і студентів,
а також покращити
професійну підготовку та запропонувати
навчання в житті застосування вбивць Може
покращити навчальні результати
Можливість отримати зберегти навички
для посилення мотивації та загалом
ця технологія
дозволяє
навчатися  від викладачів та закладів,
до яких ви не маєте фізичного доступу, але
про загрози
гм,
окрім
сценарію Термінатора,
ми спостерігаємо, як із
використанням GPT студенти досить часто гмм
зловживають ним, і іноді ви не
розумієте, чи виконується та чи
інша робота  учень або зарядка також
[Музика]
існує нерівномірний доступ до штучного
інтелекту, і це
ще одна велика проблема – це порушення
конфіденційності, коли ви використовуєте штучний
інтелект,
гм, особисті дані студентів можуть
збиратися штучним інтелектом,
і це можна робити без
дозвіл, тож ми можемо дійти
висновку, що
цей тренінг у The
[Music]
Meta Overture має свої
сильні та слабкі сторони, і їх слід
мати на увазі, дякую, Даша, ми намагаємося
пришвидшити та завершити наше
обговорення диска вчасно, я б хотів  Я хотів би запитати
Ханну з практичної точки зору як
вчителя,
якими мають бути
наступні треті кроки для
запровадження цифровізації в навчальний
процес,
тож спочатку
ми хотіли б мати схвалену
концепцію цифровізації
освіти, яка
залишається
в розробці міністерства  вже два
три роки ми повинні мати чіткий
вектор нашого розвитку, ми повинні
розуміти, як вирішувати проблеми,
які можуть існувати в цій сфері,
цей другий
ну в рамках цього проекту ми
навчилися багато досвіду у наших
іноземних колег ми  хотів би
зараз запровадити цей досвід в українській практиці, щоб отримати наш власний
український досвід. Мені випала нагода
відвідати Фінн Лондон, ми були дуже
вражені
розвитком цієї системи в
Фінляндії,
нас
це дуже надихнуло, і ми б  хотів би
почати це робити, і третій великий крок:
краще відступити від
ресурсів у паперовій формі до електронних
ресурсів, наприклад, є
гм
можливостей для
електронних
реєстрів релігійних класів,
індивідуальних електронних
мм
записів
тощо,
дякую, Ханна,
і моє запитання зараз полягає в тому, щоб  Натала, з
методологічної точки зору, чи бачите ви
три кроки для
впровадження цифровізації на
регіональному рівні,
на цій панелі ми не згадували таке
поняття, як
навчання людей із спеціальними іменами,
оскільки потребує симуляції доповненої реальності,
усі ці речі
можуть  бути дуже корисним, коли досвідчений у
людей з особливими потребами до
[музики]
хм хм з хм реальністю, і хм, наша
цифровізація досягла
такого ступеня, коли нас потрібно
ретельно навчати, як
захищати себе в цифровому просторі,
ну
в  у цьому контексті ми можемо пригадати те,
що почалося лише з однієї
людини і призвело до величезної пандемії
для всієї
земної кулі, і ми повинні запобігти подібним
заспокійливим діям у цифровому просторі,
а третій
цифровий
простір – це всеохоплююча система е-е-е
циркуляція інформації
та вмісту  аналіз освіти та
оцінка досягнень та
успіхів, які ви знаєте, щоб
зрозуміти, що відбувається, що потрібно
виправити,
що потрібно
принести
та зробити більш рівним тощо,
дякую, Наталія, ви знаєте,
і я хотів би запитати Артема, хто
стежить за нашими  ох, позначте наш графік у збільшеному масштабі
та чи є у нас запитання
[Музика]
гмм,
ми не маємо письмових запитань у нашому
потоці,
що це означає, що їм
все було зрозуміло чи нічого не було
зрозуміло,
добре, торт прибув і давайте
Підсумуйте нашу дискусію, ми розглянули нашу
тему з різних точок зору, ми
обговорили її з адміністративної чи
управлінської
точок зору та обговорили індивідуальний
електронний інтерес,
метою якого є електронні платформи, ми також
згадали якісний
освітній контент, обмін
досвідом із нашими іноземними партнерами
або
відтворення згадане
[Музика]
хм
штучний інтелект, який можна було б
використати в навчальному процесі
я дуже вдячний
за вашу увагу вони гості я
вдячний нашій власній аудиторії життя
з цим о ми завершуємо наше
онлайн-обговорення Алексі
хм будь ласка  підсумок,
о, по-перше, я хотів би
подякувати всім
методичним
центрам і навчальним центрам
[музика]
ваш внесок був величезним ви дуже
чуйні е-е, всі відділи наші
чуйні
у мене є багато проектів, які в моїх
планах одночасно досить часто  ми
дуже
вражені часом, тож я дуже
сердитий, і я обіцяю, що
цього року надійде обладнання для віртуального навчання, віртуальні окуляри,
і я прошу вас не боятися,
що з цифровим навчанням дякую,
і я  радий запросити вас до нашої
лаунж-зони, де всі офлайн-
учасники події будуть пригощатися
тортом з тортом,
а поки ви збираєтеся на торт
[Музика]
Я хотів би відповісти на деякі
теми, порушені сьогодні про
особисті дані  у державних
системах, таких як освітні системи,
ми підходимо до індивідуальних даних на основі
особливого законодавства про
виробництво персональних даних,
і виходячи з цього закону,
а
Міністерство освіти не має навіть
отримувати згоду
від громадян,
а по-друге, щодо
обіг електронної документації
цифрова документація має
Альтернативи та
ооооооооооооооооооооооо зберіть усі документи
в електронній формі на 100 відсотків
єдине, що ми маємо зробити, ми повинні
мати 100-відсоткову
гарантію, що е-е-е,
уся інформація буде
передана на 100 відсотків без будь-яких
втрат, дякую  ви,
хто цікавиться цією темою,
матимете можливість
поспілкуватися під час нашого
святкового частування з тортом,
тепер вони учасники, я запрошую вас
на неформальне спілкування, дякую за
увагу, всього найкращого